Deciding how to run your
application code in the cloud
can be difficult.
You have a variety of
options and probably
many dependencies
and requirements.
And it all seems so complicated.
Well, my name is
Mandy and I'm here
to show you that it's actually
not as complicated as you first
thought.
There are two main ways to
run your app in the cloud.
Infrastructure as a
Service, which gives you
maximum flexibility by providing
virtual machines in the Cloud.
Or Platform as a Service, which
provides fully managed software
stacks to which you can
deploy your application code,
but which has a more
restrictive environment in terms
of supported languages
and features.
This is a tough
choice and one that we
had to consider when building
the Google I/O WebRTC codelab
application.
This is a simple
demo application
that allows you to use WebRTC--
which stands for Web Real Time
Communications-- to perform
peer to peer real time
streaming between
multiple clients.
While the app wasn't
complicated to build,
there were some
complex requirements
unique to the
application that we
had to consider when choosing
between infrastructures
of service and
platforms of service.
Because we just wanted
to focus on the code
and not worry about
all the other stuff,
we really wanted to
use Google App Engine.
The main function of
this app is to allow
users to connect to the
server and create rooms which
another user can
also connect to.
The two users can then
stream data to each other.
The JavaScript Socket.IO
Library is extremely popular.
It is well known for simplifying
the development of networking
for real time applications.
It looked perfectly
suited for the task
as it has all of our
requirements covered.
App Engine supports applications
written in Python, Java, Go,
and PHP.
But how can we use it to
run Node.js applications?
Well, it turns out
that App Engine
has this cool new feature
called Custom Run Times.
Custom Run Times allow you to
define your own runtime stack.
As an example, a runtime
stack could be the Node.js
interpreter, using MPM
for package management
and running your
application code.
App Engine takes care of
provisioning virtual machines,
which are then used for building
and deploying your runtime
stack on to.
You also have the option
to define health checks
that App Engine
can use to monitor
the health of each running
instance of your stack.
Because custom runtimes
allow you to build and run
your own runtime stacks,
you could not only
run Node.js code, but you can
run Rubium Rails and Pearl,
too.
In fact, you can
run anything that
will run in the
Standard Virtual Machine
and which can respond
to HTTP requests.
Best of all, in many cases
you can run your existing
application code on custom
runtimes without modification.
One of the coolest things about
working with custom runtimes
is that they are really similar
to how App Engine already
works.
If you're not familiar with
App Engine development,
you basically develop
your application code,
pull in any dependencies, and
supply a configuration file
that provides metadata which
will be used by App Engine
to deploy and run the app.
You can also factor
large applications
into logical components
called modules.
Modules within an
application share
states but have their
own performance settings,
with each module having
its own configuration file.
Our WebRTC application
has two modules.
One is for the
front end component
that handles incoming requests
and is a standard App Engine
autoscale module.
The second is the custom
runtimes module written
in Node.js and which does
all of the heavy lifting
via the Socket.IO Library.
The first step towards
deploying the example app
is to place the application
level, a module level
configuration files,
alongside the application
code and its dependencies.
We then need to provide
some configuration
for custom runtimes.
And this comes in the
form of a Dockerfile.
Custom runtimes are
actually Docker containers
running on fully managed
Compute Engine Virtual Machines.
Docker containers are portable,
lightweight virtual machines
that allow code to run in
isolation from other containers
but at the same time
safely share resources
from the host machine.
The Dockerfile defines a
configuration of a Docker image
and can reference
another image which
you can use as the
basis for a new image.
In this example that's
all we're going to do.
But you can define more complex
images via additional commands
in the Docker file.
Now when you deploy to
App Engine with Cloud SDK,
it takes care of building
the required Docker images
as well as creating and
managing the containers
and the virtual machines
needed [INAUDIBLE].
Once deployed your
app is immediately
ready to start serving requests.
It's really that simple.
You can manage and monitor
your running application
through the Developers
Console as you would
any other App Engine app.
And you can also see the status
of the managed virtual machines
that are running the
Docker containers that
run your application code.
Behind the scenes,
App Engine does
all of the work to keep
your code running, including
monitoring instances and
checking that they are healthy.
Custom runtimes make it easy
to run Node.js applications
in the cloud.
And because you
don't have to worry
about managing systems
and software stacks,
you can spend more time
writing code, or even using
all the time you save for
a well deserved vacation.
Go here to find
out how you can get
started testing with
custom runtimes.
And go to
developers.google.com/cloud
for more information about
Google Cloud Platform.
Thanks for watching.
Now go out and build something
amazing in the cloud.